Anthony Lynn kind enough to call in to
this program in the middle of the first
week of training camp how are you coach
I'm Glenn and rich has hit it over to
practice you're okay
so are you in a car right now are you
okay very good you're heading over to
practice so what doe what does the first
week of training camp mean for you what
are you looking to achieve in that
situation coach for you you're looking
at the guys will learn your system you
know he's getting football shape you
know the first couple days we didn't
just go zero to 100 we he's back into it
because God's been gone five weeks and
and then looking for competition you
know we have some good competition going
on in this camp and we gotta figure out
who's gonna be you know and I started 22
and as a coach itself know this is when
we learned personnel and our players and
we got to figure out how to win with
what we have you know your team's change
you're not the same you know it won't be
different and so you know how you did
last week you may have to do a little
differently this year so where are the
hot spots for your competition what are
you as a head coach looking at saying
okay this is where my mind could be
changed or jobs can be won we're in
specific rustic soil with office of line
you know right now with Russell Kuhn out
you know we have some young tackles and
are competing for jobs we have a young
guard forest lamp and are competing for
a job with Scofield and Feeney and he
looked over their own defense side of
the ball you know with trevor williams
michael davis at the corner position and
trevor also can play slot competing with
Desmond King right there at the free
safety spot we brought in the second
round pick Nasir and we are a shining
star right now in Jalen walkins
competing for that spot you know we have
pretty much a new linebacker room and a
lot of compensate good competition our
linebackers I mean just everywhere you
turn you know you look at got plenty
situation to young guys that you know I
really have strong legs so a lot of
interesting competitions going on all
right let's talk about all [ __ ] cuz you
know this is not something that's in a
sling not something that's in a cast not
something that's really something that
an MRI could check on a pulmonary
pulmonary embolism is no
joke how do you expect to get him back
coach you know we hope you know rustles
rustles one of the best left topples in
the game but right now we're looking out
for Russell and it's no wait I'm putting
back on the field while he's on blood
thinners and things like that because
it's just too many bad things that could
happen but we just let it you know we're
hoping and praying that this gold goes
away and whenever he's ready you know we
definitely welcome him back well we're
not gonna rush him back out there
anytime so yeah of course but when do
you think somebody went I guess when do
you expect the recheck to occur to try
and maybe even get him somewhat cleared
as you were not a missus this is that
this is the the blindside protection for
for shut up here I don't like to put a
timetable on Klum so rather than on
football illness or injury I don't like
to put a timetable on that because you
just don't know you know you love the
housing week one but uh that's not
likely I think the recheck is at end of
this month and so uh he you know we just
we just hope for his sake that the blood
clots are gone away if not then you know
if this could go on all year Anthony Lin
Chargers head coach joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show when was the last
time you you chatted with Melvin Gordon
Anthony we chatted last week you know I
just want to know one last time if he
was going to be here or not and you know
he told me his reasons why and now I've
been a player of been in his shoes I
understand where he's coming from but
you know I also told him that uh you
know I suspect everyone to be here
that's on the contract but you know the
others don't we feel like he has to do
and and I said what we understand but we
love for him to be here we miss him and
I hope this gets worked out it's
interesting how you say you know you've
you've been in his position before so
how much of that part of your brain
works when you have but at least you you
you do try to flex that muscle when
you're talking to say because obviously
look
I equate it to you know when my
contracts up right and and and the
person who I deal with the most on a
regular basis at the NFL Network are
here at AT&T they don't get involved
because once this thing eventually ends
there's got to be a working relationship
I'm wondering where young where you land
on this subject coach well I mean I've
been working relationship and that's
looked at my conflict because you know
it's my job you know the build these
guys up and make them believe that the
Superman and they want to start getting
paid like Superman I kind of back up Tom
so let's go home to that but I still
yeah that's my general managers job I
trust him and he trusts me and we have a
great working relationship and and I'm
pretty sure national get this worked out
long way or the other
well what does he bring to your team
Melvin Anton well he's definitely a
starting runner this ladies you know
he's one he's one of the elite runners
in this league you know
you know he's physically stuff when he
shows up in big games you know he comes
to work every day he works his tail off
he's a hard-working young man he's a
young back but uh you know as I said we
miss it and if he's not here was going
to miss him but I do have confidence and
and I running back room you know I do
believe you know we have the right
pieces to get the job done and like I
say it's our job to figure out how to
win what we have and I think there's
always a way to win what you have you
just gotta figure that out so we can get
the job done but you know it'd be a lot
easier with him well I appreciate by the
way coach that you didn't give me one of
my three favorite coaching cliches if
you don't mind me running through them
with you it is what it is is one of my
favorite coaching cliches I know do you
use that sometimes with the media is
what it is to use them what it is okay I
don't recall okay
also you can can I don't have a crystal
ball right did you ever use that I don't
have when when we're asking like hey
when is Melvin Gordon coming back then
you would then respond with right
exactly
and then might and then my third one is
I'm only talking about the guys who are
here which you didn't give me right
there
but you have
[Laughter]
so if you if you use all three of them
in a row okay at some point I will I
will donate what - whatever favorite
charity you have I would love to Anthony
Lin Chargers head coach here on the Rich
Eisen show you know interesting I've
spoken obviously to ton of your players
for various reasons one because they're
they're not only star players but
they're their players on a successful
team Melvin
Ingram we just had Derwin James Joey
Bosa one thing that these guys seem to
all have in common is they love ball and
they that's that's like also the only
thing they want to talk about is ball
did do you pick up the same things with
guys like that who you're the most
likable guys on the team I mean this
whole team is very likable but I mean
those those guys outspoken except
facility I don't know how you get
anything out of Joey but I mean during
James I mean every month there's a get a
love fall I'm now I love their passion
for the game they bring a certain amount
of energy and I always tell these guys
one of those energy that's focusing and
that's what we need right now but it is
here we need focus and who was the guy
that you played with that similar to
these guys I mean again we had Derwin in
the in in studio last week the only
thing that he was remotely passionate
about football similar was Madden
football so it's just there is some sort
of football in his brain that's always
24/7 a guy that you played with or if
coach before that that was similar from
all of me the first guy who couldn't
understand and show up you know we talk
about a passion for the game outspoken
energy I mean it was eye-opening by
passion and outspoken as Shannon was but
and still is but a lot of guys like that
you know I can know what junior he was
he was like that you know
business like blind young you know use
what this is like but but still have a
great passion for the game Steve Young
you know in a way you know rod Smith I
put a lot of guys that I just love this
gameis I mean I think the results showed
Terrell Davis there's another one that's
right TD so Pat Bowlen is going into the
the hall this weekend Anthony I'm
wondering what you got a good
recollection here something you want to
say the floor is yours is the Boleyn
family finally gets to see this enshrine
and can't you know I was saddened that I
couldn't be at the service it was just
the first day my foundation was
launching our first golf outing and I've
been playing for for quite a while and
in the service came up the same day but
mr. Bolton I think is one of the best
owners that have come to the National
Football League I know when I was look
at the kind to me and kind of every
player on that team and he it always
gave us he was always competing I mean
you talk about ownership competing all
fulfil he was always trying to find in
the banners yeah give us an advantage
and he gave us all the resources we
needed to get the job done and that's
what I was known about him the most was
it was a very competitive owner but at
the same time compassionate and he cared
about his players and his coaches a
couple more minutes left with Anthony
Lin Chargers head coach here on the Rich
Eisen show were you in favor of replay
being opened up for pass interference
coach well you know we had to come up
with something rich we have to do
something because we we don't want the
egregious calls going on calls and I
know were so uh you know this game is
roughly the only human and it's going to
be airs and we can eliminate all there's
in this game that's just that's
impossible and I don't want to slow this
game down I've never been a guy that
want to put flags on the field I never
gonna fan on that but you know if this
this could help us get the egregious
calls out of the game and then I'm all
for what about the unintended
consequences of opening up replay for
something else and then suddenly now
again you're a perfect example of a
perfect example of this Anthony Lynn
that has been placed in front of
me at the NFL media group is being
placed in front of everybody I'm sure
you saw it Phil um al reveron was the
Thursday night game last year where
we're your team with a pass interference
defensive pass interference call on Mike
Williams set up on the one-yard line and
then you ran the same play essentially
two times enrolled by the way great call
all right and and so but the initial
defensive pass interference penalty
would have been wiped out do an
offsetting penalty this time around
because replay would have been opened up
to see if that was the correct call on
dpi and it would have come back well
that stands is called because we can't
tell one way or another but we sure can
see Mike Williams pushing off and it
would have waved it off coach and your
your your season could have been
completely changed from something like
that you know as long as long as you get
it right as long service you know and
this year under the same circumstances
that you know there'll steady so I just
that's just the way it is but yeah it
would have affected our game potentially
for sure but I think the main thing is
just trying to get it right
are you telling me it is what it is is
that what you just did right there and
you can control only what you can
control you I think you just did that to
me
did you just all right if you could only
have worked in there you're talking
about only the guys who are here right
now you know I would have donated to the
Anthony Lynn foundation I would have
done that right on the spot the rest of
training camp at any point during
training camp or the season just
whatever okay you got it you got it
thanks for the call coach really
appreciate it and whenever you can make
it up the 405 just up the 405 or right
here down down the road from there your
beautiful future new stadium hopefully
after February but okay you got
take care you got its Anthony lunch
Chargers head coach for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app